[Music]
in both representations which have just
come before us there is present the
unity of self-consciousness and
spiritual essence but they are still not
equally balanced against each other
in the bacchic enthusiasm it is the self
that is beside itself but in corporeal
beauty it is spiritual essence
the stupor of consciousness and its wild
stammering utterance in the former case
must be taken up into the clear
existence of the latter and the
non-spiritual clarity of the latter into
the inwardness of the former
the perfect element in which inwardness
is just as external as externality is
inward is once again speech but it is
neither the speech of the oracle holy
contingent and individual as regards its
content nor the emotional hymn song and
praise of the individual god nor again
is it the meaningless stammer of the
bacchic frenzy
on the contrary it has gained a lucid
and universal content a content that is
lucid because the artist has worked his
way out of the initial enthusiasm
originating wholly from substance into a
definite shape
this shape is his own existence which in
it all its stirrings and impulses is
permeated and accompanied by
self-conscious soul and the content is
universal for in this festival which
honors man there vanishes the
one-sidedness of the statues which
contain only a national spirit a
specific character of the divine nature
the handsome warrior is indeed the glory
of his particular nation but he is a
corporeal individuality in which r
swallowed up the fullness and
seriousness of meaning in the inner
character of the spirit which bears the
particular life the demands the needs
and customs of his nation
in this kenosis this externalization of
itself into complete corporeality
spirit has laid aside the special
influences and sympathies of nature
which as the spirit of the nation it
contains shut up within it
its nation is therefore no longer
conscious in this spirit of its
particularity but rather of having laid
this aside and is conscious of the
universality of its human existence
paragraph
726 brings to a close
this subsection of the
pretty sizable religion portion of the
work it's always a good idea to take a
little pause and think about where
hegel is going to have us going after
this
and the ground that we have traversed up
until this point and i think
particularly with the ending of this
section that can be
quite helpful so where are we going next
well let's remind ourselves of where we
currently are
we're in a middle section of the
religion portion of the work and this
this middle
section has been about the religion of
art and you could say well there hasn't
actually been
a ton of discussion of art as a matter
of fact we've talked probably
more about this this cult in german
cultists and the location or
mediation that it's providing between
the human being the worshiper
and the god
and you know it has this function of
bringing together a community the
ethical nation that hegel keeps talking
about
and that's all true
but we have seen some
development taking place in going back
from the natural religion section which
culminated in the
worker of of the art right the um the
varkmeister and where we have this
transition to the kunsler the actual
artist
and we have all sorts of uh
ways in which we're working with
things that are
kunslich right artistic creative you
could say but creative in the way of
transforming
nature and also culture into something
that can
stand in for and allow
the communication
of the divine and i'm using that word
communication deliberately given the
content of this section and where are we
going next well the
spiritual work of art and here is where
hegel
is going to turn his attention to things
like
the epic right
and the way in which the gods and and
even more importantly human beings
are depicted in the epic and then the
tragedy um so we're talking essentially
about
something that was very important for
for germans and indeed europeans of that
time uh ancient greece ancient greece is
taken as sort of like the place in which
civilization or as hegel it's a spirit
is moving itself forward
i don't think
personally
that we have to confine ourselves to the
perspective that hegel himself
more or less willfully adopts thinking a
very heleno-centric
way of looking at things because if we
are attentive to
what happens in the religions and the
art of other cultures other
civilizations in the world we'll see
similar dynamics playing themselves out
and i think we can say that also about
this subsection
that we're in so there's this this
progression that is taking place here
we've had natural religion in the past
we moved on to religion in the form of
art and we had a previous section where
it was the abstract work of art gave us
you know the mediation the cult and all
that we had to transition just recently
in this living work of art to saying
well you know the natural
or nature
gods of
dionysus or bacchus and ceres
demeter are not
adequate for for the religion that we're
talking about here there's other gods
higher gods that we're going to have to
engage with gods that
are more universal in a certain sense
and we move away from just the statue
and all of that
provides us with to
a human being and the human
body inhabited by spirit
and incarnated spirit you could say
as the new locus
that we have to
pay attention to and that's that's
what's happening
in this final paragraph
of this subsection
we can also say that
once again
language spraka or speech however you
want to translate it
is now
coming to the prominence
and
there's something going on here that's
that's really quite interesting
hegel is is telling us what kind of
language
we're not talking about
languages that we are
modes of language that we've already
brought up and explored
he's not fully telling us what the new
mode of
language is and why is he not doing that
well let's be being developed in the
next subsection right and once we finish
the spiritual work of art which is uh
quite a long
section right
um
or subsection rather
we are going to get to the revealed
religion and we've already seen some
discussion of ophenbaron revelation
manifestation the way that that miller
translates it uh in this this
subsection that we've just
are now
finishing up with so let's look at the
actual text so he says
in both representations what are the
representations of the darsta
right and the representations are
the
the statue
the statue within the locus of the cult
not just the statue
in
an art textbook or in a museum or all by
itself in a vacuum you might say but the
statue that exists for the
cult worshipers
intergenerationally providing them with
with a place to encounter the god
and also you know do their own work with
the statue and around the statue what is
the other one the human being like you
said going back to the previous
paragraph the one who comes forward who
is the pattern movement the smooth
elaboration and fluent energy of all the
participants the inspired and living
work of art that matches strength with
beauty so what we're talking about there
is a human being who may have a whole
bunch of other extras in the great drama
around them but who is in some respect
incarnating representing uh providing a
locus for the encounter with the god but
notice as well
that in the previous paragraph and in
this paragraph hegel is is very much
making this not just about the god as
some transcendent inaccessible thing
like it was way back in the
self-consciousness section where there
was this infinite distancing between the
eternal and the human being and the
unhappy consciousness now the individual
person who has been selected is
incarnating the god and hegel says that
in both representations there's
something there right what is there the
unity of self-consciousness the
self-consciousness section again is
worth thinking about the unity of
self-consciousness that was not there
in the self-consciousness section not
there in the unhappy consciousness but
now is available in this
this mode right and spiritual essence
guys take a vase and um but
there's a very important but here
they're not on the same level he says
they're not equally balanced against
each other one is
better than the other one is more
developed than the other one represents
a progression an achievement a
culturation right building that is
developing through religion so he talks
about two things
back enthusiasm which we've encountered
before the untamed revelry of nature in
self-conscious form right and he says
that what we have there
is the self beside itself now that's a
interesting
mode all right
the self
outside of itself
not just beside itself outside of itself
it is you know to use another uh word
that hegel doesn't bring up a lot but
say heidegger does and so do other
people around that time influenced by
him
ecstatic right it stands
outside but is still the same thing so
the back of enthusiasm
is something now enthusiasm the god
blowing into you the spirit of the god
going into the
right but this places you in an ecstatic
state where you can't really grasp your
own self-consciousness
because in a way you're losing yourself
what about
corporeal beauty he says in corporeal
beauty it is spiritual essence so it
better captures what spiritual
essence geistic avaisin actually
is and the rest of this paragraph is
drawing out what this is supposed to
mean he tells us the stupor of
consciousness it's wild stammering
utterance in the former case
so those are not good things stammering
right doesn't actually know what it's
saying uh the stupor it it it has
enthusiasm it is ecstatic but you know
this is a bit of a digression here right
sometimes people want to make hegel into
a mystic or you know some sort of person
who's into
you know
could be connected with psychedelics
hegel is not like that at all hegel is
for things being made manifest to
a rational being
and being able to be shared between us
not some secret little thing that you
have by yourself for the initiated you
could say that there is a hegelian
initiation but it's an initiation of and
through the dialectic which is what is
available to us as human beings and has
become more and more available to us
over time including through religion so
he says
these need to be taken up into the clear
existence of the latter corporeal beauty
and the non-spiritual clarity of the
latter
uh into the inwardness of the former now
here's where he says something
i think very
worthwhile mulling over he talks about
this relationship between inwardness and
externality or exteriority right he says
the perfect element in which inwardness
is
just as external as externality is
inward so
before we say what that is let's think
about that for a moment we have
we talk about ourselves right we we all
have
you know a world inside of ourselves
that we're not entirely
uh conscious of and which can be brought
to
consciousness through
memory
recalling things i mean this is
something that
has been known for a long time the the
notion that interiority or inwardness is
a particularly modern thing that's
that's nonsense you can find this in all
these great spiritual traditions and in
ancient philosophy and culture in the
western world so
this notion of there being an inwardness
to us and that the inwardness is in some
respect
greater deeper more complex than that of
raw being like a stone or plants or
animals
this is something really central
at the same time inwardness exists
through externalizing itself how do you
know that somebody has a thought you
can't crack their head open and look
inside you need to actually see the
expression of that thought and very
often as we've seen in the hegelian
dialectic going from the idea to the
actuality the vehicle kite the reality
of something there's usually a
disconnect between those while there's
also a continuity and we get to see what
an idea really looks like when it's put
into to action
so
externality itself also has
a kind of inwardness things are not just
what they appear to be
on the surface even in the externality
of them so we can we can go inside and
find something more
by actually paying attention to what's
out there in what we consider to be the
superficial or the merely practical
we also find more
how do we do that
what's the medium for that
language
speech
spracha
this too is part of our human nature
this too is something that has developed
over time and become more complex
this too
is something where we have a task
of reintegration and
interpretation and understanding going
on
this is very important
so he says the perfect element in which
inwardness is just as external as
externality is inward is once again
speech
now he tells us what it isn't what kind
of speech are we
not talking about or no longer talking
about while these do remain in in place
as part of
the way religion is done right so he
says it's neither the speech of the
oracle
the oracle why not
because this is wholly contingent and
individual as regards its content right
the oracle um is arbitrary
i mean it's telling you things
oftentimes you're like well what the
hell does that mean
sometimes you find that out to your
detriment think about the case of
craziest right
um or for that matter socrates right
the other
nor the emotional hymn
sung in praise of the individual god
nothing wrong with hymns we've seen that
hymns convey something very important
but that's not what we're talking about
here
nor
he says going on
the meaningless stammer of bacchic
frenzy which is
speech but speech you could say
in a
degenerate or totally metaphorical
or automatic poetic form
where we're saying like boom boom boom
boom making some booms right or whatever
else it's going to be
what's wrong with these
why are these not
adequate or sufficient
so here miller uses this term lucid they
lack lucid content this is clarin he
could have said clear
content
lucid sounds a little bit cooler right
lucidity
but there's also a lack of as he's going
to say
universal content and he says
what we've got in the language that's
being used here is a lucid and universal
content a content that is lucid why
because the artist has worked his way
out of the initial enthusiasm
originating wholly from substance into a
definite shape a gestalt right
this shape is what well who's the artist
here so hegel's moving through this
pretty quickly who's the artist it's the
individual human being whose
corporeality
is what is being placed front and center
and you could say corporeality that's
just your body well what do you think
you talk through
or understand through language which is
not the body but also is of and in and
through the body
isn't it
so he says um
this shape is his own existence
which in all its stirrings and impulses
is permeated and accompanied by
self-conscious
soul this is
an important notion here
higgle doesn't often talk that much in
the phenomenology about zoll about soul
zela right
but here he does and what is the soul
supposed to be the like
individual
inwardness of the person
well remember the the inwardness is
becoming external and it's becoming
external in part through the body and
what you see
from the body but also you could say the
body as a communicative matrix
not just talking but gesture not just
uh what it says but also how it moves
and we could also imagine other elements
in there as well
so he says that um
the content is universal
why
in this festival
which honors man or humanity mensch
right
what is actually being
dealt with
he says there vanishes the one-sidedness
of the statues and what's wrong with the
statues the statues are
in some respect
to
particular to confining they are you
could say a not quite universal
universal
so a statue of hera or zeus or athena or
poseidon or pick whoever else you like
or it could be a mosaic could be
whatever else you want is a static
representation
of a particular
manifestation of
divinity of the theos the god that is
beyond
the human
he says
the the statues of a one-sidedness which
contain only a national spirit
very interesting term here
nazi and all geist he doesn't say
a
spirit of a people
instead he uses this word nation not
cinahl
geist
the mind you could say the mentality
of a
nation
of a grouping of human beings that
identifies itself
as such
so athena could represent athens
and we could say is this the
you know athena of athens or the athena
of this athenian colony when we look at
particular statues right
hera
zeus
more
transnational
in the sense of applying to many
different city-states
each statue is still like the the you
know the zeus of corinth or the zeus of
thebes or things like that
and hagel goes on and he says so this
one-sidedness vanishes
uh a specific character of the divine
nature
what's it what's replacing it he says
the handsome warrior is indeed the glory
of his particular nation
but
something else is happening here
what what else is happening he is a
corporeal
individuality
in which are swallowed up the fullness
and serious of meaning
and the inner character of the spirit
which bears what there's a nice listing
here
the life laban demands
on legend the needs
the durfnisa the things that are being
you know
shown to be
necessary
and the customs the zitten
customs you know this is or we could say
morris is is quite important
um bears the particular life that
demands the needs the customs of his
nation so
any particular
person
who is engaging in this religious
expression
involved with language in some way but
also
through his corporeal or her corporeal
individuality
is
both representing all of this the the
national spirit
the life demands needs customs
of their nation they they don't come
from nowhere right they are an athenian
they are a
theban they are a spartan they are
whoever they they happen to be
but at the same time they become
something more universal
than that
how so
well here's where
miller is actually adding something in
this kenosis
this externalization of itself
into complete corporeality kenosis is
not there in the text
what is kenosis that is a theological
term that comes from
meditating on the emptying of oneself
of
this this figure jesus christ in in
christian
theology and practice and text
comes from the word kenos which means
empty or vain like when we talk about
vainglory that's canodoxia right so
kenosis is this emptying
in christianity the
incarnate god man
is willing to die on the cross is
willing to allow himself to be subjected
to
humiliations torture scourging and
execution and actually die right this is
going to be talked about more in the
coming
section
the revealed religion so we don't have
to talk about that much here but there
is similar things happening as we've
seen already discussion
um you know for example the god is
willing to let itself be bred for us or
wine
for us
and we could think about this in terms
of other
major
significant parts of human life as well
the gods
are willing to
externalize themselves and this is what
happens here so hegel talks about this
externalization
and oysteron
of itself
and of of whatsapp well both of the god
but also of the
actor the dancer the the individuality
who is representing with their their
very body the god in this festival and
thereby also human being
and this and oysteron is this
externalization is something different
than
merely bach enthusiasm having the self
outside of itself ecstatic
things
it is externalizing itself
into complete corporeality he says
and he says spirit has laid aside the
special influences and sympathies
of nature
which as the spirit of the nation it
contained
shut up within it
and this is where we can talk about like
the geography the particularity of these
people identifying say with a forest or
with a river or with the sea or pick
whatever else
you want that's all nature and nature is
not to be just you know gotten rid of or
despised but it is to be
transcended and one way that you can do
this
is through this progression
here
through
language and you know if you think about
this for a minute
how the hell are we
21st century late moderns
able to get anything
and make any sense
out of ancient greek or for that matter
egyptian
or
hebrew or
iranian and we could go all over the
world with this religion
well
it's not just by going to museums and
looking at you know religious artifacts
or statues and being like oh wow that's
really cool you know look how they
depicted uh zeus or uhura mazda or thoth
or pick whoever else you want
we do so by
reading the literature
and thinking about it
right that is coming through
language that's how we
recapture reinterpret some of this
we would do so even more if we did have
a cultist and we had a representative of
it as the perfect corporeality in this
case but very often we don't have that
right
so he goes on and he says
its nation
is therefore no longer conscious
in this spirit of its
particularity it's
setting aside
its particularity
and it becomes conscious of the
universality
of its human existence now how is it
doing that
again this is a bit confused at this
point we don't have a real resolution
ending this
paragraph because we've got a tension
here between language which is
okay it is corporeal and that we talk
with our our mouths and here with our
ears and tippy-tap on our keyboards and
look with our eyeballs and we could go
on and on we even braille we can feel
language
there is that
and yet there's also
the in some respect muteness of the
corporeal individuality
but these are being brought together
as something greater than these other
forms of language including that of the
bacchic frenzy
so the stage is being set
for
a new way of
understanding a new way of
worshiping
and that's where this section is coming
to
a close
you